In your book, you have a section on GCMAM.
What is your current recommendation with GCMAM for a patient with double-hit lymphoma?
What are your current results from using this treatment?
What is the current availability?
And where, if this is a viable approach, what testing, AMOS, or NAGELACE, is recommended track progress?
Well, we can see a fast answer, because we don't use GCMAM.
It's considered an invasive treatment legally.
We can't use it.
Now, there are some other clinics that are getting GCMAM.
We've had discussions about this for a number of years.
The place that it gritted where they made it was shut down.
Somebody on the last Zoom call mentioned that that company has restarted again, maybe a different European country.
I don't remember what the answer to that was.
And you can get it again.
The GCM that was available in the between years was out of the Philippines.
A lot of doctors that I know that we're using it said the results went drastically.
So they didn't think that it was an equivalent product.
So you will have to contact a different clinic about getting GCMAM because we don't have them.